huge congratulations on your engagement
Leah show us can you show us the ring
oh it's blinding it's blinding
it is spectacular tell me everything
about how you pulled it off okay
assistant everybody need a customer
right there and that's when we started
dating um and so I thought it would be
right if we went back to Costa Rica
again and I popped the question and
um it was it was probably one of the
most perfect the best the best the best
moment of my life I mean I I wouldn't
have wanted it any other way
amazing it was beautiful from getting
there the the places stayed at uh the
gifts that you had it was
it was completely it was super mindful
um
more gifts beyond the stunning
engagement ring
actually one of my is actually right
here so this is one of the gifts this is
a Keepsake so the uh I'm gonna put my
hand behind it but uh
the speech that I gave her
um I totally I said not only do I want
you to remember it but I want you to
have it forever
I got this for her
every single day
I mean at first
and it is every day like I've opened up
and allowed it a loud love in and for me
I just never wanted to push her you know
what I mean I never wanted to push her
to trust me I never wanted to push the
girls to trust me come here just been
like you know what when you're ready
you're ready and I'll be here waiting
for you now Jalen you have made it very
clear how how special your relationship
is with not only Leah but with her three
daughters so now that you have proposed
and you're going to be in the girls
lives forever did you have conversations
with their fathers about you know I'm
going to be in the girls lives now so I
actually had a conversation actually me
and Corey went uh we went golfing and we
actually we actually had a discussion
about it and he was and he was all good
with that and I've also had discussions
with Jeremy uh throughout and after and
and he's always been like you know hey
man I'm just glad you're the one that's
that's in my daughter's life you know as
becoming that stepdad and so for me like
that's just another thing too is that
when I came to her life I was like I
wanted to make sure that I had a
relationship you know with their dads
and
um and this and that and that's been
amazing too so
um and they've been all for it they have
been also giving me you know a lot of uh
wisdom from things that they learned and
so this has all been kind of a working
thing but yeah
yeah so we actually we actually filmed
some some scenes with with me and Corey
hanging out and
um and so it's just it's just all good
it all feels right I mean it feels great
that we can co-parent together just the
other day Corey was in here and we were
talking about different things that you
know with the girls become a teenagers
how how are we gonna how are we gonna
work together as a team and of course
you were a part of that conversation and
it I mean it feels great and Jalen
getting the the girls promise rings was
that a surprise to you Leanne why was it
important for you to make that such a
special day not just for Leah but also
for for your future stepdaughters so she
had no idea and they absolutely loved it
um and so yeah I just you know I told
myself listen I'm making a promise to
you guys forever that I'm willing to
show up do the hard work you know it's
always going to be easy you guys gonna
have you know things are going to happen
on the way we may have things that
happen along the way but I want to stick
through it and be here with you guys and
support y'all so the engagement is so
exciting now you know we have a million
questions about all things wedding so
first things first do you have a wedding
date we have ideas you know that we're
looking at a year from now yes
um so but as far as specific date we're
still gonna take some time and
are you thinking destination wedding are
you thinking West Virginia wedding where
in the world would you like to do it
the destination wedding
yeah
Jalen you seem hesitant
uh I mean we have we have throughout
some uh some different locations
um definitely we thought about some
places that we could go that would look
good
um maybe maybe back in North Carolina
we're gonna go out and visit and talk to
the wedding player sure yeah okay are
you thinking big wedding or are you
thinking small and intimate wedding at
first I was very much like intimate
wedding and I'm
like why not let's have a big wedding
let's have a big wedding what are the
three must-haves on your wedding day
well I mean I'll
traditional I want to walk myself down
the aisle that's a big one for me you
want to walk yourself down the aisle
yeah it's empowering for me I think I've
show strength and how far I've came
um as an individual as a woman and
everyone don't have the same family
Dynamics so it's okay if maybe that was
a little different and you want to walk
yourself down at all it shows for me
it's stress like I'm gonna be nervous
I'm gonna be excited but I know even
just looking into Jalen's eyes like
that's it's calming for me so I'm like
that's that's one big thing it's one big
thing for me I must have for me is going
to be a good DJ in the Dance Floor
nice you gotta have a good reception
that's gonna that's gonna be the the fun
the fun part so that's what I'm I'm
hoping for a good open warrant Dennis
foreign
[Music]
songs that we would say like you want to
use I think you just heard one thank God
by um
[Music]
easy on me by Adele with a piano yep
walking down the hill yeah we talked
about that we heard that we was like yes
[Music]
what is the third wedding must have you
get some definitely steak or chicken you
gotta have that
um but yeah I would say that just some
really nice like how do you look at
menus like I'm gonna travel and look um
different
but a good I guess they some good
chicken yeah Leah have you been trying
on wedding dresses I mean do you
envision yourself doing a princess ball
gown something sexy Aaliyah's helping me
pick out all of that stuff she is very
very fashion forward with all the
achievement in Vera Wang which I will be
we'll see I know but she's very um we
don't have to really Factor forward and
want to be a huge part in the dressing
everyone do you think that the twins
will be Maids of honor and Addie will be
a flower girl how do you envision their
participation on your special day I
think Ali and Elena will definitely be
bridesmaids Junior bridesmaids Alexander
to be a part of doing the makeup doing
the makeup she really does an amazing
job
um she's very artistic like that and
then I really want to leave this thing
but I don't know if she will I don't
know if she will but having 200 people
yeah yeah February like they'll get a
little shy so but I but I mean that
would that would be great if she if she
had Tucson yeah do you think you will
televise your wedding we are opportunity
to under certain circumstances I would I
would say I would absolutely yeah under
a certain circumstances because honestly
everyone that has watched my story
unfold
for years now 13 years I would love to
them to see like they saw the lowest
moments they saw like this would be my
highest moment to not be able to share
that with everyone it wouldn't be ideal
it would not be ideal but I mean it just
again it would depend under a certain
circumstances because that's our big day
like we want to we want nothing but joy
laughter family as long we don't we
don't have to worry about what cameras
are going to be positioned and that you
know we just got to make sure like it's
all like fly on a wall type stuff like
we're just not good just there so yeah
being part of this big beautiful teen
mom universe that you've been part of
for such a long time who from that world
will be scoring an invitation to the
Leah and Jalen wedding we don't know if
it's going to be a team of universe
wedding it might just be a family I
think yeah yeah yeah it might just be
family and friends
um but you know we'll see I think we'll
get to that point
um yeah
what's next proposal marriage kids yeah
do you want to be a dad
she's trying to get me to school
what is that one moment in Teen Mom next
chapter that you're most excited for
your fans to see
I would say it would be the journey
leading up to the proposal I think it's
going to be spanned out over a couple of
episodes that is going to allow people
to see a different side of me
um and
the relationship you have with the
girl's dad
I think maybe that'll answer some
questions and you know so we'll see
let's see but it's going to be good and
Jalen I love that you say that we're
gonna get to learn more about you
because Leah I wanna I wanna just give
you the floor for a second you know I
follow you on Instagram and you posted a
whole thing do those things online
bother you he wasn't accustomed to this
world and he he joined it with us and I
think even being a part of it with us
and loving us through it has also came
with
conversations we've had within our
relationship like oh my gosh like this
is this is crazy we know how how the
feedback from so many things negative we
can get to you mentally and seeing him a
little hurt like it was like hell no
like I know what this can do to you
that's my man my man
go ahead you get a little defensive yeah
I think that immersion level where it
was like
you know they don't even know who I am
as a person they never been they never
step the foot inside this house and
never shook my hand before they never
talked to me before and I I get that and
I think that um I've always said that
When the Smoke Clears we'll see be like
we'll we'll still be here together I saw
that and I knew she was doing it but I
knew that she had my back
and that made me feel
um very special and so um and this is
when I want to be there for the rest of
my life this is why you guys have such a
beautiful relationship no rush I know
you're just in the beginning stages of
planning your wedding but you know the
the topic of Family Planning is that's
something that the two of you have
talked about maybe one day expanding the
bunch yeah the girls wanted us to have
another girl yeah
boy or a girl
oh my gosh Jalen over here ready for
baby number five
I'm a twin you've had plans
for more than a week
[Music]